he done this and found somebody other  than Devon hey honey it's just funny I  mean oh why don't you man up see for me  it's like all of a sudden now you want  to be creative to stop great no why  don't you put your best defender on them  and let Devon go on Oh on and see if he  can stop that that to me is more  impressive than triple teaming and  that's what they just did they filed on  purposely wouldn't you dad cooker  looking down at the Utah bench he knows  that the game is going on and Spaulding  telling Booker I was trying to get it to  you see but here's here's the thing  right I get what Quinn Snyder's doing  and that's fine  but again I stayed I say it again man up  right  I mean wild a certain you want to be  creative now to stop I mean look the  sons aren't going to be in the playoffs  things like this for the songs are he I  mean just the bill to their progress  till next year give them confidence